our entire world is completely reeling
out of control tonight we pair respects
this room Sunday we tear it down it
totally feels surreal you know this
place where we spent so much time and
will never be the same like it's over
it's done in 2010 we've our number 50
and from then on our goal is to become
best restaurant in the world now we have
achieved that what's next we won't be
number one forever for me an empty plate
is such a beautiful thing like an empty
piece of paper or a white canvas
anything is possible
there is thousands of people cooking
they all have empty plate and that's the
beginning for your creation and it's up
to you where you're gonna take it
everyone who cooks has that same
starting point it's inspiring to look at
the empty space because I think an empty
space is more beautiful than a space
with the wrong things on it so you gotta
be very careful what you start to put on
to that empty space and maybe I've spent
22 years thinking about what to add on
to that empty plate other technique more
ingredients more garnish and other sauce
the crispy element and only in the last
three years or so I've really started to
really take away and the taking away
part has been the most difficult in my
career I think we're slowly succeeding
but it's definitely the most difficult
cooking that we have done because the
thing is when you want to express
yourself with very little ingredients
that's hard and as I have grown as a
chef our food has become much more
minimal
I think it's so important that we have
opportunities to improvise we're talking
about Miles Davis here all the time you
play the song but then you get to take
your solo
that's where no two shows are ever the
same it makes coming to work more fun
for us and I think it makes the
experience more special for the guests
[Music]
when Daniel and I first started here we
had this ambition to be one of the great
restaurants in the world and there was a
period of time where we thought we could
never achieve our dreams in a room so
big and expansive as this one and then
we had a moment of realization where we
came to terms the fact that we are in
New York and we want to be a New York
restaurant the grandeur the energy that
theatricality of this room it's actually
exactly what we need this is my office
leave the decor and the graphics I think
are what pulled me in and there's a lot
of history it's it's the art deco the
Chevron patterns everywhere so to me
it's a very special place in New York
so for each service we have about 20
cooks in the kitchen and then we have
about 10 Porter's at a time and for a
double service we have about 60 people
inside the kitchen it's quite a big
production I'm prepping the rhubarb
garnish for the summer of yes it's one
of her signature cocktails here it's a
cocktail with st. Germain some jalapeno
pickled rhubarb a little bit of agave
and de beer that's made specially for us
[Music]
the restaurant is 11 years old and so
we're kind of featuring the 11 most
important dishes of the past 11 years
and that's the meal tonight some of them
were really important to us
creatively they were like a breakthrough
moment like one of the dishes is the one
I serve to get me the job here one of
the dishes is a childhood memory ritual
that I had with my mom it's a very
emotional to go back through these
dishes and when you taste that food
again it brings you back to that moment
[Music]
when it comes to hospitality a lot of
people say like you're either born with
it or you're raised with it but you
can't teach it and I could not disagree
with that more we have on our team a
position called the Dream Weaver and it
started because we wanted someone in the
restaurant every night to bring ideas to
life
maybe we overheard a guest say that he
never had a New York City Street hotdog
so we'd run out and get one and kind of
cut it up and make it look fancy and
serve it to them when people know that
you're listening and they have these
experiences that they know no one else
is having it's a really beautiful thing
in 2010 we were number 50 in the world
and from then on our goal is to become
the best restaurant in the world now we
have achieved that I mean it's
unthinkable I never thought that we
would be in this position it's a it's an
unbelievable feeling and it motivates
the teams so much but at the same time
yeah what's next what is this new carrot
we won't be number one forever
[Music]
we are gonna renovate Eleven Madison
Park will will close for four months we
can really truly make it our own home
now we can build it the way we exactly
want it because we've lived in it for so
long
what's different about tonight is it's
the last time any of us are gonna be in
this space together and doing dinner
service and because of that we're
closing for renovation
tonight it's a little bit reunion a
little bit celebration a little bit
nostalgia and it's just gonna be
electric it's the biggest rock concert
we could ever be a part of okay good
evening guys tonight is a special night
as this is officially our last night of
service we're pressing reset and we're
starting all over again after 11 years
us being here in 19 years this
restaurant being here but these past 11
years that was a big chapter for many of
us here for me that was the biggest
chapter in my life I don't think there's
a space a place that I have spent more
hours in at this place right here after
today this place is gonna change forever
our entire world is completely reeling
out of control tonight we pay our
respects this room Sunday we tear it
down
I do feel honored by the army of human
beings it's taken to get us from where
we were to where we are but there is no
group I'd rather be standing here with
right now today fired up
so duck have a good service
[Applause]
[Music]
it totally feels surreal you know this
place where we spent so much time in
will never be the same like like it's
over like the last service is done the
way we knew it it's done
but the last few nights the energy in
the dining room was unbelievable they
loved the restaurant and you can feel
that most people say why do you change
and then sometimes I'm like yeah why do
we change but we have to change as soon
someone would say I think it feels a
little bit tired then it's too late
and we don't want to miss that moment
and so we're excited for this change and
we really believe that the time is now
you know it's funny like in in my whole
career I really thought about mostly how
to add things how to add courses how to
add ingredients how to add techniques
and I think only in the last two years
I've started really to take away and I'm
realizing that taking away is much more
difficult than adding things that type
of cooking I could have never done when
I was younger because I guess maybe I
wasn't confident enough all the fields
walking through the dining room
downstairs it's crazy I've never seen it
like that before with all the artwork
down
it's just weird it looks naked and so
it's kind of bittersweet but exciting
especially I don't know knowing that the
crews gonna come in here and start
wrecking things and rebuilding pretty
soon so
[Music]
I mean today's crazy today so far this
will never happen again because our next
lease doesn't run out for 20 more years
and probably not gonna be as much into
spray painting the walls when I'm in my
late 50s all I'm thinking about right
now is about how I want to spray paint
the rest of the walls in this building
at the moment but I know it's not good I
need to get that out of my head because
I feel like I could get a lot of trouble
[Music]
so when I started here I inherited the
kitchen so for the first time I can
really design the kitchen exactly the
way I want it I know exactly where I
want my pots to be where I want my
knives to be what station should be
where but of course there's a little
fear as well
this place has a special soul and this
soul has to be really protected and in a
way we want the room to feel like even
more like the room what it originally
was as we've been packing up we found
all these memories it's fun to relive
everything and I think it gets us even
more excited about what's to come it was
an idea that someone had I think was
will or chef for someone where you know
we had to go through this renovation we
want to keep our staff like let's find a
way to keep everyone employed and what
does everyone in New York do in the
summer they go to the Hamptons so it's
perfect when I think about summer I
think there's always those movies there
like the great late eighties early
nineties movies and so many of them
started with like the bell ringing and
it was the last day of school and
everyone running down the steps and for
us as restaurant people were working to
create an amazing restaurant in the
Hamptons but also to really bond with
our team so by the time we come back
this fall our team will be tighter than
it has ever been
[Music]
we've never all lived together and I
think that brings out a lot of the
dysfunction that actually makes family
family and so just together live
together to work together to play
together to celebrate together and maybe
this is just maybe more grown-up summer
that hopefully if we do it right isn't
too grown-up
[Music]
[Music]
my motivation with every dish I create
is to make the most delicious food I can
this is no different out here this is a
more casual setting and I think this is
an amazing opportunity for us to work
with the food and the farmers so close
and the goal is to just express these
products in the most pure pristine and
in the most delicious way
[Music]
the main reason that we're out here is
because we're undergoing this renovation
and you know Eleven Madison Park is
gonna be beautiful but the most
beautiful restaurant in the end of the
day is nothing without the most amazing
team that we have so that created a real
challenge for us what are we going to do
with our team for a period of four
months and so I think we created an
opportunity for our team to bond and
when we come back to the city we're
going to be stronger than ever and in
this last four days that we've been out
here going through the preparation of
opening this restaurant the most
exhilarating thing for me it's been just
to see our team and just appreciating
our team how amazing they are
welcome to the NPS summer house what are
we doing here you know this is sort of
our reflection of a restaurant by the
beach when we were brainstorming what to
do with our team during this renovation
we thought of what a real New York
restaurant would do and we thought it
would go to the Hamptons and then we
thought about what a restaurant in the
Hamptons would be like that we what we
will want and this is kind of what we
created yeah yeah it's crazy you're here
right now probably almost exactly a year
to the day after we started working on
this and like many good things in life
it didn't come easy finding housing for
125 people in the Hamptons not easy
finding cars finding even this
restaurant we probably looked at 25
different places and and I feel like as
hard as it might have been we were
really lucky along the way so this is
definitely been a feed but it's been a
lot of fun coming out here I sort of
joke and say we opened this project on
Bubblegum's and dreams all of our other
projects we have over two years to sort
of develop and create and focus on and
it was crazy because we just closed
Eleven Madison Park last week packed up
the restaurant on Monday and Tuesday
shipped everyone out here on Wednesday
and basically started setting up on
Thursday to be honest I was a little
worried about what was gonna happen but
the space is amazing and you know the
team has been doing such an amazing job
these guys have been killing themselves
but the space looks great but there's a
lot of things in Easthampton that are a
bit different that we've never had to
deal with like raccoons and bugs and
pollen and neighbors uh-huh let's just
try it out this is the farm house at the
farmhouse
I built the pétanque courts boccie
courts whatever we want to call them and
so fire pit all right good what do you
think I mean all you we can get some
chairs and put a bunch of a fire pit
right here you know for all people
[Music]
I guarantee you this fall we will work
in the most beautiful perfect kitchen
you will ever work in so during this
time I just asked you guys to be
flexible you know understanding I hope
you guys have a good time and we're out
here to represent our brand in a whole
new way and the product we have today I
feel very confident you know that we
will and and I'm really really super
super crazy proud of you guys
guys here we go it's starting tonight
we're gonna open a restaurant it's gonna
exist for ten weeks the ratio of the
amount of time invested to the number of
hours will actually be open is
unreasonable and I'm really excited it's
in the top of the Philly right now is
the last moment where this place is
truly ours we've built this like built
it with our hands mostly Natasha's hands
but other people's hands as well and in
like 20 minutes it's not totally ours
anymore in 20 minutes we kind of give to
this gift to the world and in one sense
that's sad
but in another sense and this is why I
love doing what we get to do is that
we've poured an unbelievable amount of
time into creating something and in 20
minutes we're gonna stand back and watch
the world freak out when they experience
our creation I hope you guys also
realized that how special of a time this
is for everyone for everyone involved
with 11 medicine like this year has been
tremendous and so many challenges but
also so many exciting moments and this
is just another one and let's create the
best restaurant in that the Hamptons has
ever seen
have a good service
[Music]
you